hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the air things masters 2020.
uh it's a wonderful game uh from day two
between the neil dubovo and maxime
vashilagrav the uh
clash for first place has already been
decided between temura jabo and levan
arena but now we still have to see
uh who won third place so it's a it's a
brilliant game
if you remember on the first day uh dubo
started by winning two games and then he
just needed a draw
but then he again played a very
attacking chess and then he lost game
three and game four
so maxine tied to the first match and
now everything will be decided in the
second match and this is the first game
of the second match
uh i thought it was the absolute
craziest one so i decided
i will show this one and this is the
last game we'll be showing so without
further ado
uh duba with the white pieces opens with
uh not with that with e4 sorry about
that
uh we have c5 by maxine he goes for the
sicilian defense as he usually does
uh knight to f3 d6 and now bishop to b5
dubo goes for the canal attack
knights to d7 blocking check and not
just castles
uh we have asics challenging the bishop
asking do you want to capture do you
want to go back
uh dubo goes back it looks like a funny
square but he is planning c3 so he will
make
a room for the bishop so knight g to f6
and now
c3 uh making room for that bishop
we have b5 and now preparing bishop to
b7 so white immediately challenges that
with a4 so now there's a double attack
on the pawn here
and black could go c4 and push his
bishop back but it doesn't really do all
that much for black so instead
we have bishop to b7 completely ignoring
the attack on the b5 pawn
as the e4 pawn is now also under attack
and here characters on b5 we have
captures and now a rook trait uh
sorry about that uh rook captures an a8
bishop queen captures an a8 and now uh
knight to a3 and knight to a3 is a new
move in the position
in all of the games that have reached
this position so far captures on b5 and
captures and e4 was played but here
we have knight to a3 and it is as a move
10 that we have a completely new game so
let's see what happens here
uh maxine continues uh with bishop
captures on e4 all the same whereas
b4 could have been uh very interesting
but
uh that's just the thing this was never
played before maxine probably didn't
know about it and
uh it does look very dangerous for
example before knight b5 goes after c7
you can deliver
a nice royal fork here and then after
the queen moves for example rookie one
defending d for pawn
and even though this is uh perfectly
fine for black even
the best uh reply from black
you don't want to go into straight into
dubose preparation
so maxime continues with the normal
stuff bishop captures an e4
bishop captures and now knight captures
duval grabs the pawn on b5 now
threatening knight c7 check to win the
queen and the queen to b7 and
incredible as it is uh dubo is now
completely winning
but it's uh it's not easy to figure out
why he's completely winning
so i'm just gonna show you because it's
really really crazy
uh queen to b3 wins the game for white
uh point is that you're threatening a
very sneaky plan
d3 kicks away the knight and then knight
captures here with
check wins the queen that that's your
plan and it seems like a simple plan and
it seems like black can do something
about it but not really
for example if black just continues uh
doing nothing with e6 then the plan is
that
just d3 kick away the knight and after
the knight moves you can just go capture
zero with
check and win the queen so obviously
we're not gonna go with that
so what you could do is get the queen
out of the way you could play queen to
c6
but it doesn't help just d3 kicks away
the knight
knight e to f6 and now bishop to g5
and there's nothing uh black can do here
because once the queen moves from the
defense of those squares
uh rook a1 to a8 just wins the game
there's nothing for black to do there
uh because uh you can even sacrifice the
rook or
rook day one rook to check queen
captures and then knight the c7 check
will
win the queen on a8 and if you try
something like knight to d5 to try and
get the knight to help out with the
defense
even queen captures and d5 is an option
for example queen captures knight c7
check wins the queen back now
white would be up material and if you go
for the b
uh b5 knight then again rook to a1 and
there's nothing uh that you can do here
rook to a8 is coming
and that's just it uh knight to b6
trying to attack and defend the a8
square
just queen b7 and again there's no
defense against rook to a to check
even if the knight captures the queen
here false so that's uh that's all there
is
so incredibly uh interesting uh
already and move 12 dub of completely
winning but it's uh
it's a very very sneaky idea uh he did
not find it he played c4 here which is
also a great move
defends the knight and now he wants to
play all of this that we've just shown
so e6 by maxine
d3 kicking away the knight knight to f6
and now
even d4 he wants to open up the position
with d5
we have bishop to e7 and now d5
we have e5 by maxine and now with e5
maxim is able to close down the center
but he gives up control of the f5 square
so here knight the h4 dub of ghosts for
the f5 square and now
g6 by maxine uh and of course bishop to
h6 now
not allowing maksim to castle so dubo
needs to uh
uh so maxim needs to figure out a way
how to how to develop here
so he goes back bishop to f8 he says
okay you you you'll either
move the bishop and then i'll move the
bishop again or we'll trade i'm somehow
going to play king g7 bring my rook into
the game and
uh then i'm perfectly fine however the
game is now again
completely winning for dubo so now feel
free to pause the video and to win the
game for white
this is such an incredible move i i
don't think we've ever seen such a move
so uh while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations as
uh i don't think this is uh
even possible to find over the board and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's bishop to g7
and this is a crazy idea because the
bishop of course cannot be captured if
you capture it just knight captures on
d6
check wins the queen so what else could
you do you could play
rook to b8 of course just try and save
the rook but
white was never interested in the rook
white was interested in the knight here
so bishop captures knight captures and
now
again queen to b3 now wins the game as
this was all the point moving that
knight from here so the knight does not
cover the b6 and b8 squares
and now again we have the threat of
knight captures winning the queen
and once the queen moves again rook to
a1 just wins the game
as there is nothing for for black to do
here knight d7 just
rook to a8 and that's it queen captures
you can play knight c7 check
pick up the queen and there is no
compensation here uh for black
so what uh you could do after this
bishop to g7 move is really nothing you
could try
giving up the queen for two pieces but
it's simply not enough white has a queen
a knight and the rook and the white will
win this easily and even a past
b pawn so after bishop to f8 bishop
to g7 completely winning for duba he
misses it he pushes f4 he wants to bust
open the position
open up uh the files leading to the
black king so he plays
f4 and e for now maxime closes it but e4
is
again a really bad move because it again
allows bishop to g7
so now what happened here was either
maxime
also didn't see bishop to g7 or he
realized the dubo
didn't see it and then he just tried to
play a reasonable
move uh as he figured maybe dubo will
not see it on the next move also
and the duo doesn't see it on the next
move he tries queen to b3 right away
but it doesn't work now queen b8 and the
knight is just guarding the queen here
so it's not a problem the queen and
bishop guard here so
there's no way to take advantage of this
so here
bishop captures an f8 was played and now
king captures an
f8 so the attack has slowly evaporated
queen all the way back to g3 probably
with ideas of f5 going after that
d6 pawn so maxine kicks the queen back a
knight to h5 queen back to c3 now
attacks the rook here
rook the g8 and now g4
attacking the knight knight to f6 and
now even g5 trying to get the knight
back here where it will be trapped
uh but here maxim just finds knight
captures on d5 and of course if you
capture then black captures the knight
on b5
so queen to d2 was played now with an
attack on the knight also the d6 pawn
will be attacked twice
uh knight to b for by maxime and now uh
dubo was able to stabilize the the
center and the queen side and now he
wants to continue pushing on the king's
side
f5 and even though maxime is up material
with that
rook being out of the game it's still
dubo who's attacking here
knights the d3 and excellent square for
the knight here and now
even f6 by dubo and uh
you might think but why not uh for
example capture
on g6 and give uh give white an open
file
after h captures and g6 it doesn't it
doesn't look like there's much you can
do here to
continue this attack and it might only
be easier for black to activate if you
give him uh for example the the h file
for the rook
so instead f6 by duboff he prefers to
keep that rook locked down
and now and now maxine shows why he's
such a such a strong player and such a
resourceful player
here he pushes h6 this is how he gets
the rook into the game he's gonna play
rook to h8
he's gonna play king to g8 king to g7
and then he's going to bring the rook
into the game
that's his plan so duba captures on h6
and just rook h8
uh we have queen to g5 by dubo now
preparing to shift the queen over to d5
to get a double attack on the d6 pawn so
knight seven to e5 not allowing this
queen to d5
idea and now duba goes rook to a1 with
the knight on b5 he wants to get his
knight over to a7
king the g8 and now rook to a7 again
double sets the deadly trap
uh if maxine continues with his plant of
bringing the king to h7 then
dubois just wins on the spot rook
captures on f7
it doesn't matter that the square is
defended because queen captures on g6 is
checkmate
so maxim spots this and he says nope
that's not happening he goes queen to f8
adds another defender to the f7 pawn
and now now again we have a critical
position here
uh just a crazy one where i'm not even
gonna ask you to pause the video because
uh
this is just uh in such madness to find
such a move would be
uh would be well you you would have to
be
rated at least three thousand here the
strongest move for white is king to f1
and this just allows white to continue
whatever white was planning to do
because as long as the king is in g1 you
constantly have to worry about knight f3
check and you're gonna lose the queen
so this knight cannot move and you're
just uh
out of good moves so king to f1 is what
white has to play here
but double started the the attack right
away he played knight c7
and now yes rook to a8 will win maxime's
queen
but there's a problem uh maxine can hide
with king to h7
but also he can play rook to h6 and even
sneakier idea that maxine finds uh
point is that uh after rook the a8 which
was played in the game
now maxine just plays queen captures on
a8
and now there's a problem uh whatever
you play for example if you capture the
queen
then rook captures an h4 and there's a
problem again
of queen captures because knight f3
check just wins the queen
so now we see some of the problems that
occur because king to f1 uh was not
played
so after uh this uh rook captures on h4
uh you would maybe have to play
something like queen e3
but it's just not possible a knight f3
check king if one rook captures here
and now the queen is stuck there forever
uh if the queen ever
moves just to rook to f2 will be
checkmate the knight covers e1 and g1
and
the knight here defends the rook so it's
just a nice checkmate
so here after queen captures an a8 uh
duboff does not capture the queen
rather he captures the rook and now
threatens mate in one
so can't maxime defend against this
queen the a1
checked by maxine king to g2 now queen
captures on b2
with check uh we have king to h3
and now knight to f2 again with check
and here comes king the g3 we have queen
to c3 with
check and now of course if you capture
you allow knight to the g4 check that
wins the queen
so here king the g queen to c3 check
king to g2 and now uh for the last time
feel free to pause the video and to win
the game for maxime
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on trying to force
the white king to capture the knight
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to h3 check
and now of course if you capture again
knight the g for check wins the queen on
h6
and if you don't if you trade try
something else the dual played king to
g1
but now just queen captures on h2 with
check
uh if you capture again uh there's not
much you can do here
or rather this runs into knight g4 but
it it
it is actually hadoop played if you try
running away it's actually a force mate
queen h1
check king e2 queen d1 check again you
cannot capture queen e3
check and now finally after you move
king to f4
you're gonna get knight the h3 checkmate
so really uh amazing stuff here so after
king captures um
uh queen captures an h2 check king
captures was played
and now finally uh we get this chicken
knight fk
the g4 check king g3 and the queen is
captured so this is how maxime defends
against
checkmate and now it's two knights
against two knights but maksim
is up three pawns and that's just too
much king of four was played
now comes even knight f5 attacking the
knight here so
knight captures pawn captures and now
knight to d5
uh we have knight captures on c4 king
captures on f5 but now
maxine just starts pushing his pass pawn
knight f4
guarding against uh pushing the pawn to
e2 but the just d5
taking away these two squares from the
white king so dope has to go all around
d for now king to f3 and now knight to
d2 with
check king e2 and 94 and it was in this
position that daniel dubo resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the pawn is hanging here
and if you try something like knight h5
to defend it you're going to get c4
so d3 is coming there's nothing you can
do about it if king f3 even king h7
you just go after the pawn you don't
even care white can never capture
because just e2 is winning
you're getting a queen into the game so
no point in continuing after 94 uh dubo
resigned and
maxime won the game which means he's now
leading
uh in their match and i'm now going to
mention what happened in the rest of the
games
game two ended in a draw game three
ended by dub of
winning and then everything was to be
decided in game four and it was
uh in game four maxine vacherola grab
one and maksim was sherlock won third
place in the air things masters
so really a wonderful uh wonderful
game all of the games between these two
gentlemen have been simply incredible
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed uh
watching them as much as i enjoyed
showing them
uh but i i don't think you did i i think
i enjoy it much more
uh but yeah uh that's it for this game
and for the coverage of the tournament
really hope you enjoyed
that uh the next tour uh or the next
part of the tour
uh starts on 6th of february so we're
gonna have
the entire uh january for for more
visage and for some of your suggestions
so we'll see what happens there
and for the end of the video here is a
nice photo 11 arnon posted on his
twitter feed
of his dog pawnchick there you have it
11 and poncho
to improve your day look at that look at
that good boy there
i've been told a poncho means donut in
russian so that makes the
the little gentleman even cuter look at
him
so i just wanted to share that with you
guys and levin also opened a twitter
account for poncho so if you want to
follow pawnchick's adventures i will put
a link to ponchex
the twitter profile in the first thing
in the description below
yeah if you want to check it out uh but
yeah once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
saisharankupa a capcom company richard
pineal
zachary lumpinen and samuel cheryl for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day